hey guys we have just reached 900 000
subscribers and it would not have been
possible without you so thank you from
the bottom of my heart
I want to remind you that I am doing
this for you
I want to bring value
to your lives because what I learned
from my two brothers who passed away is
that life is short
and you can't use it to spend it on the
wrong things
you need to make the most of your time
to make the right decisions and to live
life to the fullest
and so you can expect to see a few
videos
as we grow closer to 1 million
subscribers
that will challenge you as a man and I'm
looking forward to it
so I'll see you in the next video and
always remember that life is short
so do not waste yours
cheers guys